[Musique]
voici pourquoi j'ai décidé de commencer
mon sujet ce soir on est bien d'accord
tous ici dans la salle on a envie de
prendre ce bébé dans les bras 9 pas ça
tombe bien c'est ce qu'il souhaite
de l'autre côté
cette deuxième photo nous montre
clairement un chat qui a faim alors ces
deux photos ont deux points communs
la première c'est que les deux
protagonistes ne possède pas le langage
ça c'est clair
et la deuxième raison le deuxième point
commun c'est que ces deux protagonistes
clairement nous manifestent quelque
chose qu'il souhaite ardemment
alors j'ai une question pourquoi dès
lors qu'on acquiert le langage nous les
hommes les femmes
on n'ose plus demander ce que l'on
souhaite
alors ce soir j'ai envie de vous dire
demandez c'est obtenir
il ya trois semaines je dînais avec mon
ami maille elle m'explique vraiment
déçue qu'elle vient de recevoir une
lettre de refus pour l'obtention de son
fils dans un collège privé
alors évidemment je lui pose la question
et je dis mais tu les a contactés tu les
a appelés pour comprendre pourquoi ton
fils n'avait pas été acceptée et à
mesure 20 non atteint on a déjà été
refusée on va pas en plus essayer de
comprendre avoir dénoncé un peu la honte
quand même ok mais pourquoi il est si
difficile de demander alors j'ai
réfléchi et je me suis dit que peut-être
demandé c'était faire acte de faiblesse
alors pour ça on va prendre un exemple
imaginons totalement au hasard il ya
quelques années avant l'ère des gps
vous êtes au volant monsieur vous êtes
samedi soir assis à côté de votre femme
vous conduisez vous êtes complètement
perdu pourquoi est-ce que vous n'osez
pas simplement ouvrir la fenêtre est
demandée excusez moi monsieur pourra les
sépare ou à droite ou à gauche
et ben oui demander son chemin c'est
faire acte de faiblesse parce que
quelque part on dépend de l'autre on
accepte que nous banon on n'est pas
assez fort on connaît pas la réponse
alors on n'ose pas demander peut être
également parce que on a peur du
jugement des autres
c'est le cas s'il ya parmi vous des
étudiants qui n'osent pas demander à
leur professeur alors qu'on n'a pas
compris les non c'est mince
bah oui mais attend tous les autres ils
vont se moquer de nous et bien des
études montrent que la plupart des
meilleurs élèves ce qu'on dit qu'ils ont
une scolarité brillante et bien figurez
vous que c'est ceux qui ont le plus
demandé alors une autre raison qui me
semblait moi en tout cas personnel on
n'ose pas demander parce que peut être
on n'a pas envie de savoir la réponse
réellement par exemple chez le médecin
moi j'y vais souvent sur mon iphone je
note une liste de questions que j'ai
envie de poser à mon médecin
et puis en fait j'arrive et souvent bas
je pose pas toutes les questions parce
que quelque part j'ai pas envie d'avoir
toutes les réponses et la dernière
raison qui m'a semblé intéressante pour
expliquer pourquoi on n'ose pas demander
c'est surtout parce qu'on imagine déjà
le refus de l'autre personne
et oui c'est le cas lorsqu on hésite et
qu'on refuse souvent de demander une
augmentation à son patron dommage en mai
non mais moi j'ai eu des bons chiffres
mais bon par rapport à mes collègues et
puis si je demande une augmentation par
rapport à l'entreprise par rapport à
moins de plus simple un que je justifie
non et puis de toute façon en ce moment
c'est clair il va dire non mais pourquoi
j'ai envie de ce soir de vous inviter à
oser demander demandé tout et n'importe
quoi alors il ya un cas il ya un cas
ou dans 88 % des réponses salle est
positive et en plus elle est immédiate
et en plus si on rajoute 11%
figurez vous monsieur que cette réponse
est positive c'est simplement qu'on
avait envie de vous faire mariner un peu
et oui c'est la demande en mariage
dans 99% des cas la demande en mariage
vous allez obtenir une réponse positive
et pourtant
bah on n'ose pas et alors c'est d'autant
plus grave
dans le cas d'une demande en mariage que
quelquefois est bien de ne pas demander
sa future fiancée un mariage et bien
elle va se dire que vous avez peur
d'engagement et du coup finir par rompre
dommage quand même alors le mariage
c'est un bon exemple
parce qu'en réalité est ce qu'il ya un
autre une autre occasion de vivre tous
ses rêves en une journée avec ses
proches et sa famille le mariage c'est
magique on peut tous réalisés
j'ai quand même une question alors on va
faire un petit sondage cents huissiers
parce que vous êtes très nombreux ce
soir levée juste la main qui s'est déjà
ennuyé un mariage elle soyez franc quand
même et ouais j'avais bien peur de cette
réponse
en fait c'est pas du tout que les futurs
mariés n'ont pas de rêve pas du tout
c'est que quand on se lance dans
l'aventuré d'organiser un mariage et
bien en réalité les futurs mariés vous
recevoir des tonnes d'offres très
standardisé pas du tout personnaliser
mais qui souvent sont quand même plutôt
sympa et du coup ils vont sur battant
finalement c'est pas mal ce qu'ils nous
proposent le traiteur le photographe
vidéaste et c'est extra alors mon
travail aujourd'hui c'est d'organiser
une journée de coaching pour les futurs
mariés ou le matin je leur explique
justement quels sont vos rêves à vous
deux comment vous imaginez cette journée
magique et l'après-midi et bien
étonnamment je leur explique comment on
demande précisément à faire rentrer
ses rêves dans son budget et ça pour
chaque prestataire
alors assez parlé mariage quand même
parce que ça va pas concerner toute la
salle l'idée c'est de se dire est-ce
qu'on peut pas cette phrase qui nous
semble si simple si évidente demandé
c'est obtenir
est-ce qu'on peut pas justement alors
que c'est très puissant l'utiliser dans
d'autres domaines alors cette phrase
simple évidente mais très puissante
jeulin karl dans ma vie professionnelle
vous l'aurez compris mais aussi dans ma
vie personnelle et ça c'est un cadeau de
ma mère le 27 février 2010 ma mère
françoise j'en parle avec d'autant
d'émotions ici à l'opéra de limoges
qu'elle est né à limoges
le 27 février 2010 ma mère s'est éteinte
d'un cancer du sein
lorsqu'elle est partie c'est pas
simplement une mère que j'ai perdu c'est
tous ces rêves pendant des années
pendant toute mon enfance j'avais été
nourrie de ses projets de ses idées de
vacances où elle voulait partir
j'avais même une liste d'activités
qu'elle allait faire avec mes enfants
alors qu'il n'était même pas enceinte
et puis elle est en elle s'est éteinte
le 27 février
ce jour là c'est tous ces rêves qui sont
partis je me suis rendu compte que la
vie était très très courte et qu'on
pouvait partir sans avoir réaliser nos
rêves
alors vous vous souvenez toutes ces
croyances et toutes ces peurs moi je les
avais aussi
eh bien ils ont tout volé en éclats en
éclats et vous pouvez demander à mon
mari et je suis aujourd'hui la femme la
plus exigeante et la plus qui existe sur
terre parce que je n'hésite jamais à
demander
vous vous souvenez mon ami maille qui a
reçu justement cette lettre de refus et
bas lors du dîner je vais parler judic
où tu sais ce qu'on va faire on va
écrire un petit mail et donc on a rédigé
un mail à la au secrétariat justement du
collège privé et on a expliqué on a
demandé pourquoi paul n'avait pas été
acceptée et pourquoi comment faire pour
que l'année d'après peut-être il un
texte scolaire
le lendemain elle à envoyer cette email
et deux heures après la secrétaire du
collège je l'appelais et lui expliquer
que oui effectivement étaient sur liste
d'attenté que certainement y aura une
réponse possible
alors j'ai envie ce soir mesdames et
messieurs de vous transmettre ce cadeau
que ma maman m'a transmis malgré elle et
pour ça il ya une méthode très très
simple pour demander et obtenir
facilement et pas uniquement pour noël
ou pour votre anniversaire
la méthode est là en deux étapes la
première étape c'est pas la plus simple
c'est qu'il faut réfléchir à ce qu'on
veut réellement
et croyez moi c'est vraiment pas une
étape simple il faut y réfléchir
tellement que vous visualisez le
bénéfice de déjà avoir une réponse
positive donc première étape réfléchir
qu'est ce que je veux réellement et la
2e étape 1 il faut passer à l'action
il faut oser demander osé demander avec
bienveillance parler avec son coeur être
convaincu et convaincant et vous allez
voir vous serez surpris des résultats
la plupart du temps les gens ont très
envie de vous faire plaisir et de vous
aider
alors est-ce qu'on peut tout demander eh
bien écoutez j'allais vous dire oui on
peut tout demander par contre attention
demander une chose à la fois
n'allez pas trop vite pas trop fort mais
une chose à la fois je vais vous donner
un dernier exemple en 2012
j'avais 32 ans et je cherchais un cdi
j'étais le stéréotype de la working girl
parisienne qui allaient chercher un
cadre où ça d'un poste de cadre à haute
responsabilité
quand je me suis retrouvé devant le
futur patron
binger pas négocier le salaire en
réalité la seule chose que je voulais
c'était des horaires je voulais
commencer à 10h
pouvoir amener mes filles à l'école et
terminer à 17 heures pour pouvoir
également aller chercher mes filles à
l'école
peu surprenant pour une jeune working
girl parisienne eh bien figurez vous que
je l' ai obtenu et c'était ça mon succès
parce que je ne voulais qu'une chose
mais je voulais vraiment très fort alors
mesdames et messieurs ce soir à l'opéra
de limoges
j'ai envie de vous dire allons-y et y
ait l'audace de réfléchir à ce que vous
souhaitez et de le demander dès demain
ça veut dire quoi
demandez le massage un votre conjoint
demander demain au lieu d'une bavette
échalotes au restaurant demandé une
bavette sauce poivre demandé et demandé
lundi à votre collègue qui vous aident
sur un dossier sur lequel vous étiez un
petit peu hésitant demandé c'est obtenir
et alors chez une demande forcément pour
terminer mon intervention
s'il vous plaît lorsque vous allez
demander mettez-vous en connexion sur
les réseaux sociaux avec moi et faites
moi part de vos belles réussites basque
a rien qui me fera plus plaisir que
justement de connaître vous désire et
surtout vos belles réussites demande est
faite obtenir
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]